even though he condemned that he also
was like well it says he was like busy
partying with Elton John at the time
some [__] so he wasn't like there's all
this like so he's like at a party and
then the the the media is asking and he
goes it's very sad and then he goes back
there
a lot of [__] going on
he's like
[Music]
how much do you guys know about what's
happening in France right now not that
much I just saw a glimpse I just heard
Joe talk about it a bunch of lazy [__]
don't want to work anymore
that's what they say about the French
they don't want to work I saw videos and
it looks like the biggest Riot that I
have ever seen it's even spilling into
uh neighboring countries I thought it
went beyond Riot now and there's like
actual resistance groups in like France
that are organized and fighting the
police engine it's actually bigger than
I've ever seen it I've seen footage of
not just riots but now like people
grouping and attacking police vehicles
yeah they've they've actually
successfully burned down a lot of like
uh buildings too but then like uh so the
the thing that I thought was crazy is I
think the last thing I saw is that they
were taking over a jail and they wanted
to release all the criminals oh that's
good that's probably where they should
start holy [__] I know that and then
like there was an old Syrian guy who
right who like got taken out by a cop
yeah you want that's where it all
started oh it's like a seven that's like
the whole thing so it's like it's like
George Floyd style like something
happens that's what set it up the 17
year old kid named Niall Algerian
delivery driver he was pulled over for
like violating some traffic law he was
like driving the bike lane or something
like that you should just get a ticket
for he gets pulled over and uh he tried
to uh basically Dodge the cops so you
know when you're like not pulling over
at least out here that's already a
signal for cops to think something else
might be going on if you speed off
exactly but if you just continue at a
slow speed then the cops kind of like
know
that you're just finding a safer place
and they'll communicate like pull over
here on the pull up with the next exit
or whatever right so it kind of freaked
them out that this kid you know didn't
were they in a car what's that were they
in a car the cops yeah but then the kid
was on a bicycle
he's in a Mercedes he's like nice girl
yeah nice car so then uh and plus they
said they felt weird that he had like
polish plates or some [__] but um he
ends up getting like getting away from
them briefly but he gets stuck in
traffic so when the cops catch up to him
uh he can't go anywhere the two cops get
up to his win at the driver's side door
they're right up to him like Point black
I at one point an officer puts a gun
like literally into the window
and like says something I think he might
have threatened him and said something
like I'm gonna put a bull in your head
or some [__] like that oh [__] and right
in French so it sounded really Pleasant
yeah
yeah oh that looks nice so obviously the
kid
gets scared and he floors it
and then that just shoots him and loads
shoot some point blank in the chest and
kills him but uh obviously that's not to
any protocol they're supposed to fall
like for sure yeah but then initially
they tried to file it as like oh the uh
the car that was moving the officer was
in direct danger of being hit by it or
something but video comes out that the
officer is actually at the window like a
drive-through guy yeah so he's not
actually in the path he was about to
give him a Happy Meal yeah but he gave
him a sad meal a very sad meal yeah so
he he uh the French President condemns
the action completely
um macaron yeah macrame Mr macaroons and
just a whole lot of [__] just comes
right after that uh even though he
condemned that he also was like well it
says he was like busy partying with
Elton John at the time some [__] so he
wasn't like there's all this like so
he's like at a party and then the the
media is asking and he goes it's very
sad and then he goes back there Milton
yeah there's a lot of [__] going on with
it
it's just going nuts yeah but I guess
this is my favorite [__] song okay do
they have like similar like police like
white black relations in a way they do
so one of the things that it's
highlighting here is that
um algerians like among other types of
minorities in France do experience
disproportionate amounts of like
suspicions like the way that we do out
here yeah but I heard that it's like
more so the fresh new immigrants rather
than like the local people well I heard
that's who mostly is upset with this as
well is that is the Immigrant Community
that's yeah yeah heavily integrated yeah
with the French population
because this is seen as a huge Injustice
which I agree with so yeah Mike wow so
is that the ones that were out
protesting the Immigrant Community
that's what I've heard through media I
don't know what's true or not I think
also like a friend of mine who's from
Paris actually said too that the general
at least where he's from because he's
from like the city and he said the
general attitude really is against this
like they're not their sentiment is not
like uh half and half the way it might
be for like Republican Dem you know like
they just generally are more liberally
do they just all hate cops or or hate
like this type of like excessive Fork
use of force or like to hit a Justice
bar yeah I think it's like corruption in
the establishment and I mean generally
like there's not a lot of people that
are on the side of the cop really
because obviously what he did is wrong
like you're you're not even allowed at
all to shoot a driver who's driving away
from you assistant it's like the
McDonald's kid we'd covered here yeah
like they just [__] blow them away
because they're because the cops of
[__] yeah yeah and uh again like even
with that even though the cop was like
no I thought that was the guy from the
other day that had run away from us
he ended up being right it kind of was
that guy I think but it doesn't matter
like you're still not allowed to just
shoot not like that even in a country
like France where it's even this is even
less common yeah that this type of thing
can happen you're still not Judge Dread
bro yeah right especially a 17 year old
kid I don't even think he was armed or
anything like he just got freaked out
obviously that's also a um I guess it
you can't blame it for being freaked out
because normally you have a gun face
you're not supposed to point the gun at
a and you're gonna say I'm gonna [__]
shoot you dude I got pulled over I was
just about the same age I was 19 years
old I was driving in Escondido
California I get pulled over by a cop
and I don't know where the [__] to pull
over because I remember my Ted [__] in
my entire life he's like why the [__]
can't people just pull over into the
shopping center or something they gotta
pull over the side of the road now all
these lucky losers [__] looking at
this [__] and backing up traffic so I'm
like I don't want to be a lucky little
[__] make my dad pissed so I just
kept driving and driving and driving
until I was gonna get to a shopping
center but I was at a certain stretch in
Escondido where there's no shopping
centers for a while or nowhere to really
pull over unless I was going to be
obstructing traffic so I waited and
waited and waited and by the time I
pulled over to the shopping center the
cop is so [__] pissed at me that he's
like unsnapping his gunshot he's drawing
his weapon on me and [__] and then I was
just putting my hands out the window and
I was like he's like he's like he's like
what the [__] are you doing I was like I
didn't want to be an [__] with lucky
lose and then he's like looking yeah and
he's like because I was so scared I was
just saying my I was just saying my
internal dialogue right yeah yeah and
then he's like for all I know you're the
River City killer and I was like
I don't even know what that is and he's
like I don't know what look he loses
yeah River City kill him but no he was
like you know draw on his weapon and
[__] but the same same age same fear I
never pulled over by a cop you're
freaking the [__] out freaking the [__]
out he thinks he's in the high-speed
chase I could have just as easily have
hit the gas as I did like just like pull
over him weirdly yeah you're staying the
same miles per hour throughout so it's
not like you're trying to completely out
not running yeah you're not running
in in the cops mind he might be thinking
he's having a high-speed chase with you
yeah exactly yeah but I remember him
unsnapping the [__] thing taking his
weapon I was like Jesus and that's what
sucks too is like we learned at least a
lot of us did we learned how to behave
when you're dealing with cops to keep
them from freaking out yeah like it's
not a thing that's widely taught
everywhere but I learned it growing up
no sudden moves yeah just don't don't
try them because you might get a you
might get a [__] bad cop there are
people too yeah yeah and not many of
them are like former crazy ass Navy
Seals they're just regular people that
just wear a uniform too yeah definitely
right but in this case it is it is that
thing with no matter what comes out from
here if they there's a guy I'm sure
that's working tirelessly to find this
kid's criminal record or some [__]
everybody's trying to like scramble to
like the narrative work sure sure worse
no matter what happens from here we're
gonna get a bunch of new info from the
time this video comes out yeah they
already know that this was against
protocol so there's really nothing you
can say about that part so most of the
most of the pro testing is that it's not
from the because recently you know how
they just had those rights because they
don't want
um to work more yeah like the re they
were gonna raise the retirement age and
that people were kicking off hard so
that probably blended with this because
that means it's been constant problem
there's look the French just go ham dude
like if they feel like there's Injustice
they actually will learn to do something
about it yeah which I find admirable
can't respect that yeah yeah I do but
now it's getting Beyond just protest
though like I've seen I'm sure this like
took the tension and brought it to the
final point where it all just The
Cauldron exploded and everybody for
whatever reason they have against the
government is now expressing that [__]
and whatever building is burning the
sentiment individually for each person
is part of that fire yeah you know what
I mean I mean they're the ones that
killed all the Royals too I feel like
the culture is just built on like I'm
gonna just keep killing my leaders
French revolutions is no joke right yeah
we only show in the French just to try
to keep them down as much as you can
they'll kill their own we know they're
functioning they're gonna do whatever
they need to do they'll [__] they'll
be like we don't need other Wars because
we'll just kill our own leaders and I
think they're self-hating a little bit
oh yeah a little bit I feel like they
keep their leaders in check because they
[__] kill them right and then the
next ones are like all right I gotta be
a good guy geez maybe that's a good
system
foreign